Her low freak. Bitches were
kidding Eli's. We're kidding.
Don't call Elis and either to
get mad at that too. Eliza,
you know she doesn't use the last name
anymore. Well, neither does I will.
Christina is Christina pain now?
Really?
Sebastian Maniscalco was just Sebastian
now. White people getting crazy lately.
Tig Notaro has just tig.
Is that cultural appropriation?
Two's a white person do use only one name.
I always forget what's cultural
appropriation. We need to
constantly be reminded.
I tweeted something today.
I was reading a fucking article
and I almost punched my screen.
They're saying that hoop
earrings are cultural now.
Girls aren't allowed
to wear hoop earrings.
Who rail a cultural
appropriation? Damn. Q.
How fucking privileged you have to
be like how softly the hoop earrings
criticized as cultural appropriation.
Do you know how soft you have
to be to give in to that,
to give them that and how? How fucking
dumb you have to be to say that. Yeah,
you have to be so dumb and racist.
I think it's the,
it's the Israeli system is racist against
white people. Racist against black,
but what their jungle jungle people that
only wear giant fucking hoops in their
ears.
What I read was Latinas,
Latinas are criticizing it and
saying it's a part of their culture.
It's their culture. Yeah. It's
like people are just picking tack.
Black people don't want
girls to wear braids. Oh,
corn rows can't wear cornrows.
Yeah.
You could wear like regular white
people braids, but little skinny brains.
That's cultural appropriation. What
about goldilocks? She was white.
What about golf shirts?
Are they a lot of golf for eight?
They shouldn't be. If we started easy
with these braids. It's green pants.
Here's the problem. A little
bells. All this we bullshit.
The entire country is a melting
pot of cultural appropriation.
You dumped cuts,
right?
That is the whole idea of having a
civilization is that you get to share each
other's food, share each other's
recipes, listen to each other's music,
listened to each other's jokes and
stories get by each of these clothes.
You know, there was this, um,
journalists that went to Japan and
they were talking about cultural
appropriation.
Whether or not they thought that like
white girls like Katy Perry wearing the
geisha outfit was cultural
appropriation and they were,
they were like universally saying no,
we're happy that people love Japanese
culture. They do that, they're happy.
Yeah.
But over here you get these fucking
dummies that are just looking to complain
and criticize and just call out
everything and everybody about everything.
Yeah. It's a, Oh my God, I
see this. What does this, no,
Jeremy Lin. Yeah. So yeah, came
out with a, in the preseason,
I think he had dreadlocks in his hair
and a former NBA player called him out on
it. Kenyon Martin. But Jimmy Lens
response to it was actually really good.
If you want to check that
out. Hey man, it's all good.
You don't have to like my hair and
definitely entitled to your opinion.
Actually I ledge, I legit grateful
you Sharon. It TBH to be honest,
at the end of the day,
I appreciate that I have dreads and you
have Chinese tag out cause I think it's
a sign of respect and
I think as minorities,
the more we appreciate
each other's cultures,
the more we influenced mainstream society.
Thanks for everything you
did for the nets and hoops.
Had your poster up on my wall growing
up. Oh Shit. What he said, right.
That's really classy. I'm somebody really
need to tell him like, all right bro,
we get it.
You want to be black like we get it.
But the last name is Lynn. All
right, well he's who said that?
The other guy who was the other guy?
Kenyon Martin or there was a picture
of his but it's been removed.
Well he's a dummy and that Jeremy Lin
guys are very classic character for the
way you answered it. First
of all, dreads or not black,
they were assigned of people
not washing their hair.
That dates back to the
Greeks and the Romans.
There's ancient sculptures of Caucasian
looking people with dreadlocks.
Dreadlocks were warned by the Vikings
is not a black thing because some black
people wearing them does not mean it's
the idea that this is a real thing.
That's cultural appropriation that people
go around pointing at people saying
you can't wear your hair a certain way.
Like we're limiting hairstyles and it's
just so many people are just looking
forward to criticizing, getting shitty
with people over almost nothing. Yeah.
It's just no.
The whole day,
the whole energy of this country is
supposed to be complete assimilation.
Like you said,
let's pick the best shit from each culture
and may get just American hodgepodge
and that's what it's about
with gentrification. You know,
you want people to not all live in one
neighborhood and all dress exactly the
same as each other. You want there
to be a merging of different looks,
different addresses. Sure.
Working in different trades,
you know, they used to be,
if you were Irish, you were a cop.
That's it. That's what we fucking did.
You know,
we were cops are,
we were soldiers when we first came
over here and like the 1860s during the
famine,
they just,
we got off the boat hungry and they
throw a fucking uniform on us and sent us
into fight front lines against the south.
Or You were a cop.
And then after that they
got into the trades.
There's a lot of Irish people
in unions, right? You know,
a lot of Irish in the Longshoreman's
union, a lot of Irish in the, you know,
the Carpenter's union. But
look, fusion restaurants,
what's a fusion restaurant? And you
take a couple of different cultures,
you combine their food and do some
sort of a unique thing. And it's,
it was a big thing for a while.
People loved fusion. Yeah.
They love that kind of food.
And now there's a ton of
people complaining when White
People Cook Mexican food.
Like there's this famous guy, I
forget his name, can't be that famous,
I guess he's not that famous,
I forget his name,
but he's a famous white guy who
loves Mexican food. And He, um,
opened up a Mexican restaurant and all
these people got pissed that this guy is
a cooking Mexican food.
But this guy has been writing
books about Mexican cuisine.
He goes down to Mexico,
he learns how to Cook Authentic Mexican
dishes from people that live in these
villages and towns in Mexico and,
and like has a deep love and
appreciation for the culture of Mexico.
Ms Guys,
essentially a Mexican cuisine scholar
and all these people give this fucking
poor guy. That's his name. What is
his name? Bailiff. Rick Bayless.
And he's famous.
I mean I've,
I've read one of his books on Mexican
food and I've seen articles written on
them and video interviews and stuff.
And this guy is getting in,
in trouble with other people. When chefs
become famous cooking other cultures,
food, you don't own your culture.
You fucking idiot. You know why?
Because you didn't create it. You didn't
invent pizza. You didn't invent pasta,
you didn't invent Chinese food. It's been
around for hundreds of fucking years.
You were just born.
You were born with a certain ethnicity.
You don't own that ethnicity.
The idea that you can keep other people
from enjoying it and appreciating the
history of other human beings is
fucking racist. And it's stupid.
This, this thing that we're getting into,
we were criticizing people, you know,
based on various aspects
of culture that they enjoy.
It's insanity.
I know.
Think about how Italians have
affected like fashion in this country.
I mean,
from high fashion all the way down to
like the disco era when all of a sudden
music,
right? We're all calling themselves Gadi
and they were all calling al Capone.
I mean, come on man. I mean,
how many fucking rap songs like have
godfather lyrics and just cut the shit?
It's so stupid. It's so stupid. And
that's my culture. I'll tell you,
you can have it.
That's why I love one of the seminal
moments in American culture was Aerosmith
getting together with DMC and
doing walk this way. That was,
that's what America's supposed to be.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's kids today looking
to point the finger, uh,
the world they see and looking to find
fault in it and find fault in each other.
And it's this call out
culture that we see.
There's plenty of shit that's wrong
in the world. There's plenty of shit.
And I guess this is just a byproduct of
people having the freedom to communicate.
I mean, I guess that's what
we're seeing, but there's,
there's plenty of shit to
really pay attention to.
Jeremy Lin wearing dreadlocks
isn't on that list. You know,
girls that wear hoop earrings isn't on
that list. It's just fucking white. Yeah.
Right.
Kids that wear baggy pants. So what,
so what, who gives a shit? Yeah.
To me that's a sign that they're
like accepting black culture. Yeah.
They want to intern intermix.
They want to hang out together and share
each other's fashions and ideas and
drugs and women.
Yeah.